something else that is probably driving
people crazy gas prices they're getting
even more expensive went up again this
week it actually hurts while watching
that number go up triple a says the
national average for a gallon of gas hit
an almost eight year high this week
hector mejia reporting live actor
what can we expect here what's going on
well we've learned nevada has one of the
highest gas prices in the entire country
there's a gas station right across the
street from us
gas there is 399. the average in nevada
is 386 a gallon that's 40 cents more
than the national average according to
aaa and here's where we rank nevada is
the nation's fifth most expensive market
california hawaii are the most expensive
this week the national average for a
gallon of gas hit 344 a gallon that's
eight cents more than a week ago 14
cents more than a month ago and almost
an entire dollar more than a year ago
the last time gas was this expensive was
back in 2014 according to aaa and for
those who depend on gas or diesel to
make a living it obviously means a
smaller paycheck at the end of the
month it impacts everybody but i think
bigger carriers are ready for it
maybe single owner operators or small
carriers you know it's definitely more
expensive for them to run the business
and less profits
prices have been going up for months the
latest reasons for this increase demand
during the winter weather along with u.s
russia tensions driving up the price of
oil
aaa says there are no signs of slowing
in that local trucking company we talked
with said with this increase they
estimate having to pay upwards of 50
thousand dollars for a month we'll talk
a little bit more about that still ahead
in the next half hour reporting live
hector mejia live local now